[Music]
you have probably heard of blockchain
the buzz around blockchain blockchain
blockchain is the backbone of
cryptocurrencies it's set to transformed
many aspects of Our Lives
this is probably the place you might
think it is changing the game the
financial sector
what if I told you it can do even more
the blockchain revolution is brewing but
it's not where you think it is
in this two-part special I meet the
Farms
the Grocers I want to show you something
more interesting
and the startups so what do you need in
the physical world is actually iot the
Internet of Things
trying to change the world of food with
blockchains now imagine if you could
know exactly how many steps this
free-range chicken took during its
lifetime
can the technology behind cryptocurrency
really help us know our food
I get a taste of blockchain and why
matters
[Music]
the world is getting crazier
more complicated
so I'm back to help you make sense of it
all this time I'm bringing you greater
access
more engaging stories and deeper
insights I'm going to tell you why it
matters
so what is blockchain
to put it simply it's a giant Ledger
that tracks the exchange of assets like
money or goods between two or more
parties
imagine all these are digital
and are kept on not just one computer
but on many computers
like its name suggests information about
transactions are stored in Virtual
containers called blocks
these blocks are digitally changed to
one another
this encrypted data is then made
available to all the computers on the
blockchain network
making it almost impossible to change
data that's been recorded
breakthrough in data storage is what
experts believe will change the world
not exactly how from Dr Julian hosp
author of cryptocurrencies Simply
explained and so why we do this is so
that people don't work on things that
are not related to some business reasons
Julian is also co-founder of 10x a
Singapore based startup it's just three
years old yet last year 10x was among
the best funded startups in the world so
here you can see part of our team our
team is our asset investors poured about
80 million US Dollars into its initial
coin offerings buying into tenex's
promise of making cryptocurrencies
spendable
so at the next we started a bit over
three years ago and we learned about
this thing called cryptocurrencies
Bitcoin and so on and so we thought all
these virtual currencies how can we use
them in real life and so that's how we
started with the debit card that people
can connect to these cryptocurrencies
and then they can go to Starbucks and
can go to these stores and they can
actually spend their Bitcoin for coffee
what other applications are there for
blockchain technology all the blockchain
actually does is instead of me storing
information on a company server I can
store this information on myself and I
can prove that I have not tampered with
this information this is what
blockchains through cryptography allows
now how is that different from other
databases it means censorship resistance
I no one can censor what a new block
looks like one of these in info blocks
that get gets integrated and no one can
censor the past so I cannot just remove
or add something I cannot block
something so the censorship resistance
is very very powerful because it doesn't
allow one party to tamper with something
the second thing is transparency
everyone can see the blocks from today
until the very beginning so this means I
can actually see what happened what was
the data flow a lot of the data is
anonymized so I cannot see put it what
that's fine but transparency in this
system is extremely high so I can
literally see in money did money get
created did money get destroyed how much
money did actually move I cannot see the
participants now obviously an
interesting application is finance
because I can store how much money I own
and everyone knows that I didn't change
the amount so yesterday I had ten
dollars today suddenly I have ten
thousand dollars I couldn't do this with
blockchain so it's the technology very
Advanced right now but just not
widespread so I think at the moment we
are just dabbling around with testing
and seeing what's possible I think we
are in the 1990s of the internet so
really 20 years ago I think it's it's
trying it is this gonna work would a
user do this I think it's really early
Stakes right now I think it's it's
really great for for Enterprises for
governments to look into this create
sandboxes create accelerators and just
kind of no one knows exactly what are
going to be the killer use cases in the
future so I but I think we're testing
and we're really really really really
early stage right now if a country
doesn't invest in blockchain will they
lose only the end I think a government
that doesn't invest in blockchain is is
going to lose out it's just like not
investing into online you would have
lost out over the past 20 years with
blockchain there's a lot of other really
great applications I'm very very
convinced over the next 20 years we're
going to see it in all our lives
it turns out blockchain May well start
turning up sooner than we think in one
of the great pleasures of Our Lives food
I'm here at food and hotel Asia a
biennial food and Hospitality event
aside from food to tickle my taste buds
the event also gave me food for thought
had a talk on food Providence
how do we know where our food comes from
and how do we ensure that information
cannot be faked
I think that blockchain technology has
an incredible application to provenance
to ensuring that what we see on a label
is actually what we're going to be
eating or drinking we believe that one
of the best
use cases for blockchain technology is
the supply chain
I caught up with the speaker Max
cantillia after the top
his co-founder of Unchained capital a
technology company that specializes in
building private blockchains for
international companies
as someone who enjoys Fine Wine and Food
he's excited about the potential
application of blockchain on food
yep so blockchain technology is always
associated with cryptocurrency yes why
food industry then blockchain is a
wonderful solution to looking at trust
and transparency in that entire supply
chain from the pig farmer through to the
table that's because the blockchain
allows us to make every transaction
transparent and available to every
participant in that chain and so what's
on that label there for example can be
entered into the chain and it will be
seen by every participant on the Chain
so for example if the technology was
available I could just take out my phone
and scan the label and it will tell me
exactly where this pick was from when it
was slaughtered Etc even more than that
it will tell you how it got distributed
from the farm to a distributor how the
distributor went to a shipper and it
will even tell you which ship this
traveled on to Singapore before it came
to the restaurant where you might be
eating it and you cannot possibly tamper
with the information along the way
blockchain technology sounds like what
Singapore coffee entrepreneur Pamela
Chung has been looking for
Emler runs a coffee Academy and Roastery
called better Barista which trains and
employs disadvantaged women
and showing her coffee beans come from a
sustainable source is part of the ethos
of a social Enterprise
can I ask where are the beans from uh
the beans we're using today uh they're
actually um single origin coffee from
Myanmar Myanmar yeah is it really very
important for your customers to know
where coffee comes from well I think
increasingly consumers are getting quite
concerned about the Providence of food
right and ingredients where does our
food come from you know is it ethically
sustainably sourced So currently how do
you know that your beans are ethically
sourced with this Myanmar coffee we
actually have gone to the farm we've
talked to the farmers and with our
partners who are processing the coffees
there we try and see for ourselves for
example the conditions of the farmers
are good right and make sure that you
know money gets to them it's costly
right now of course a lot of time yes
yeah so it is not an Endeavor that you
know I think a lot of people can afford
to do so I think with technology like
blockchain where you can't go in and
alter the information right it I think
gives us a little bit more ability to be
transparent and authentic with that
information along the way
with blockchain hamler will be able to
reassure her customers that her coffee
beans are ethically sourced
for example to prove that she has
compensated the Farms fairly they can
scan a code which can put beside her
label to see if a fair trade certificate
has been issued to her
this will give a company an edge over
its competitors
which is why today she is meeting with v
chain a blockchain technology developer
based in Shanghai vechain made a name
for itself developing blockchains for
luxury Brands such as Renault
[Music]
right now we try to make it more
accessible for everyone right so if
everyone has a smartphone then it's easy
to verify the origins of a product so if
for instance we have a QR code that is
already embedded on your package okay
all I need is a smartphone let me scan
it and then it's verifying you're able
to see a photo of the product yep so you
assure that it is the right product and
the most exciting part is here so you're
able to see the time and date every
event has occurred in the supply chain
and who was part of it okay so this
makes your supply chain very visible One
Step event has occurred it's on the
blockchain and you can never change it
right so somebody I can't go in and just
you can manipulate that data got it so
as a consumer I I now can trust that
what you say is true okay it's really
from Myanmar this is the day that it
left your warehouse and its days it's
made to roast so I think that is
something that the blockchain can help
reinforce that you're not lying and that
what you put on your marketing
um whatever you claim that you're doing
it's true this is how the blockchain can
help you so I need to find out from you
like your processes um is there any
element of tech involved is it all very
manual for instance yeah pretty much so
I mean basically how it works is that uh
like we work with genius coffee in
Myanmar so they run a processing uh
Center in the Shan Highlands and they
work with you know the few hundred uh
smallholder Farmers there so we're doing
Harvest time they will collect all their
cherries right and bring them to the to
the processing farm and then genius and
the steam will process it and all that
right and then it finds its way onto a
ship yeah the ship comes to Singapore
Singapore we pick it up it goes into our
warehouse and then when we're ready to
roast it it goes into our Roastery it
goes to coffees right and we pack it
into these bags for consumers and then
it goes out to all our retail locations
online okay so that's kind of a chain
okay yeah so what do you need in the
physical world is actually um iot The
Internet of Things smart devices like um
for instance a QR code maybe to
illustrate the a short chain we could
have my colleague go to your retail
store okay have it scanned and then we
will bring it here and have it scanned
again just to Showcase that the location
is being detected at two different
places so that means we're going to put
it on the back yeah we'll put a QR code
on the back okay and we'll take it to
the shop
and then have it scanned so the time and
the location should be reflected on the
blockchain
[Music]
so as you can see the Coffee Bean has
arrived at Plaza Singapura okay and also
it's open for Brewing okay and there's a
time to it and there's also a location
to it Singapore Central oh yeah can we
get more specific because actually in
Plaza Singapore right which is a
specific yes Place yeah so for demo
purpose we'll showcase Singapore single
Central is very high level yeah but of
course if we work together we can
Implement that for you very easily okay
this can happen because that would be
more useful correct
the potential of what blockchain
technology can do for Pamela goes beyond
traceability
in theory when a chain has been created
from Farm to Table a mechanism to pay
for a cup of coffee using cryptocurrency
can also be done
and because of the transparency a
blockchain provides as a consumer I can
actually track where my money goes
if I don't want to only tip the Barista
but also support the farmer directly I
can do so
the application of blockchain on food
traceability is still relatively new in
Singapore
but one country is going big with it
China
and that's where I'm heading
[Music]
into a 2016 report by the U.S Chamber of
Commerce China is responsible for about
86 percent of the world's counterfeit
Goods
that's about 400 billion US dollars
it's no wonder you can't tell fake apart
from real in China
but here the problem goes beyond High
Street branded Goods
into the food we eat
with counterfeit food the bigger problem
is of course food safety from adding
melamine to milk powder to passing off
red meat as mutton a slew of food
scandals have rocked China over the last
decade
[Music]
since the infamous 2008 milk powder
scandal
China continues to be a hot bit for
contaminated and counterfeit food
[Music]
a Pew Research Center study in 2017
found that 4 out of 10 Chinese view food
safety as a very big problem
so you can imagine the extraordinary
demand for information regarding food
provenance here because the stakes are
life or death
so some food Giants are stepping up
[Music]
one of them is jd.com
the retailer is going out of its way to
track as many of its goods as possible
right down to the farm using blockchain
technology
and I can access all of that
unadulterated information from the
comfort of my hotel room
a simple search on the popular Chinese
retail platforms tells me that the
variety of products tracked ranges from
packaged Goods like milk powder
and wine
to livestock
like sea cucumbers
[Music]
JD is alibaba's biggest rival it is the
second largest e-commerce company in
China
it made its foreign to online groceries
in 2012. six years later it set up its
first brick and mortar store here at 7
fresh in paintings eachong District
JD's Flagship Supermarket is 4 000
square meters big
many of its products are tracked on the
blockchain
you notice there is a QR code in the
package I can open the seven fresh ABP
and a yielding the scan function to scan
the QR code on the package
it shows me the very is come from a
Manufacturing Company the farm
information this makes the supply chain
of the vegetable more vegetables
I want to show you something more
interesting okay
you can see there is also a club called
The Fish Bowl if I could on a fish
I scanned the QR code at gets me to the
detail information page okay you know
exactly where I came from and at which
date what time it was fetched and what
time it was tested
the grocery manufacturers Association
estimates that a single food front
incident can cost the company 2 to 15
percent of its annual revenue
[Music]
for a massive firm like JD which netted
a total of 55.7 billion US dollars in
Revenue last year
at two percent that can translate to a
loss of 1.1 billion dollars
so the fight against food fraud is
serious
they are even opening up their
blockchain to their suppliers and other
companies so they too can develop their
own blockchain applications for more
secure and transparent Supply Chain
management
former computer scientist Professor Dr
Peyton is leading the development of
this technology in JD
one of the most cited authors in the
field of Big Data Dr pay has more than
25 years of academic expertise
when we say supply chain we know where
it is but people have a hard time I mean
you know typical customers would have a
hard time to touch or to see supply
chain
concept you you can't hold it you can't
you know hold on to something like that
yeah it's intangible yeah but through
these blockchain service the chasing
service now people can really use the
benefits of blockchain to enjoy the rich
information collecting in the whole
process was it not possible before
having blockchain technology because for
blockchain one advantage is that you can
have the information from multiple
parties and those parties may not even
know each other meet each other or may
not even trust each other so blockchain
provides such a technique to facilitate
such a collaboration among different
parties in an infection and efficient
way way
now imagine if you could know exactly
when these mushrooms were harvested
or if any pesticides were used on these
vegetables
are exactly how many steps
this free-range chicken took during its
lifetime
[Music]
but in China it already is a reality
foreign
[Music]
JD tracks 14 000 products from 500
brands on the blockchain
and one of the first livestock to be on
their blockchain
sea cucumbers
[Music]
I'm in a province of leoning and around
me in the waters are millions of sea
cucumbers and you can see it for
yourself
what I mean is you can watch the
surveillance footage of one of the many
aquaculture Farms here on Chinese
e-commerce website jd.com
on the site what you see alternates
among the close to 100 cameras at random
cucumber suppliers scenery long Seafood
Company chose to upload this onto their
blockchain
which is then displayed on JD's website
and mobile application
they do so because they want consumers
to verify the origin and authenticity of
their secret numbers for themselves
[Music]
Birds
why would a company go to Such Great
Lengths to demonstrate provenance
I wondered about that until I realized
that a huge price difference exists
between sea cucumbers harvested from
different places
take these two cucumbers for example
they may look the same but I soon find
out that one costs 600 US dollars more
than the other
okay we're here in a room specifically
for storage and preparation of sea
cucumbers which is a specialty of this
restaurant that has almost a 90 years
history in Beijing and I'm also with
head chef Ann who has had 40 years of
experience with this restaurant
yes
and from my limited knowledge of sea
cucumbers I know that the more spikes
there are on the sea cucumbers the more
expensive let me try to guess which is
the cheapest first all right so let me
go for the one with the least spikes
this one has pretty short spikes but
this one looks a bit shriveled and a bit
wrinkled I would say that this is the
cheapest it's quite obvious to me that
this sea cucumber has the most number of
spikes and the length of the spikes are
also quite long the longest out of all
the six types I see over here so I think
this should be the most expensive or
Tyler yeah
so chef and you are an expert in in
Secret Compass but how about their
ordinary Chinese folk who go to the
market and buy secret numbers do they
know as much as you do now
um
foreign
[Music]
for example cost a pretty penny because
the waters they grew up in are colder
[Music]
when it comes to fraud related to sea
cucumbers it is usually a case of
consumers being corned into buying those
of an inferior grade at premium prices
nobody dies
but people are understandably angry that
they are not getting the value they were
promised
[Music]
by putting sea cucumbers on the
blockchain scenery long hopes to
reassure their customers that the sea
cucumbers they bought are worth every
penny they paid
I'm meeting Lee shangshong from sinulong
it is her job to make sure that each sea
cucumber produced by a company meets the
high standards expected by their
customers
what do you choose to show the consumers
do
it
um
foreign
it sounds like a very transparent
process
until I find out the input of data onto
the blockchain is a manual one
so the possibility of human error
remains
so apart from the live stream of
surveillance footage why should I trust
the information
[Music]
I returned to Scenery Long's blockchain
technology provider JD for answers
you know can I fix certain information
and put it on the chain is that possible
very very good question you have very
good insight into the business uh indeed
this is a great opportunity for
technology for example we can use the
iot devices to collect some of the
information like a temperature like the
environment variables and then record
such information directly into the
blockchain I see so it has to be like a
machine process and not a human not
human yeah so there's a whole
infrastructure that is required yeah for
the whole tracking system on blockchain
to be realized
[Music]
The Internet of Things or iot refers to
a network of connected devices
it is not only one of the big buzzwords
in business today it is also changing
our everyday life
today for a small price you could
already set up your smartphone to
connect to all of your electrical
devices in your home
to control the lights
play your favorite music Here's a
Spotify station featuring jazz
[Music]
or cool the air so it feels just right
when you get back home
[Music]
the catch it may not cost much to make
your home smarter but it will likely
cost tens of thousands to automate even
a small to medium Enterprise
who Bears the cost because it does sound
like a costly Venture and would the
consumer have to take up most or part of
that cost the cost of building the first
blockchain application is typically
expensive but as long as you enlarge the
application uh domain scope
then you will average out the cost I see
so at the end the cost will be low that
is also why in the next five years when
blockchain technology becomes the more
standardization technique then the cost
will be lower
so far I found out that while blockchain
is encrypted it is only as reliable as
the data it feeds on
but even if the Integrity of data is
assured what happens if the physical
product is compromised
the URL still points to the same link on
the blockchain but the product is
compromised
Bitcoin May hog the headlines but the
technology behind cryptocurrency can do
more
in China blockchain is being used to
trace food
what it means is you can access critical
information about food products using
this
a QR code or Quick Response Code is like
a bridge it connects the product which
is in the physical world with
information in the digital world
now these patterns are readable only by
machines so when you scan a QR code the
machines translate that into information
which makes sense to us
there's also NFC near field
communication NFC belongs to the
umbrella of Technology called RFID radio
frequency identification RFID uniquely
identifies each item using radio waves
and for NFC data is more securely
transmitted via a higher frequency using
a chip
[Music]
foreign
blockchain startup V chain is one of the
few in the industry that designs and
manufactures their own sensors this is
where we manufacture the our chips
different kinds of tagging tagging
mechanism so here we have QR codes this
is the NFC chip you can wrap it on the
package when you open it you will
destroy the antenna and this one is
actually a new generation of like a two
in one chip in this chip you actually
have both RFID and NFC because it's very
easy it's very friendly to the
Enterprises because an RFID is actually
very useful in the warehouse you can
scan it from long distance and scan the
products in batch but at the same time
RFID needs special reader so for that
for the end consumer the RFID is not
very easy to use so when it arrives at
the retail store you can only use NFC so
in consumer they can just scan the NFC
with their so it's it basically means
the need different needs uh from for the
warehouse and and the consumer
[Music]
so I understand there are different ways
to access a blockchain can you tell me
more about it right it doesn't matter
like QR code RFID or even NFC chip is
just a way to tag the product so we
design different methods based on the
nature of the product and also based on
the value of the product because if you
tag the product with the chip of course
the cost is higher than a QR code so we
are actually working a couple other like
wine uh wineries wine producers they
have some high-end wine which like over
a thousand like RMB or something that
make it makes sense to put like NFC chip
on those products
this this place is actually uh so this
is the wine and you have the NFC chip
here it shows you how this NFC chip can
be placed so you use NFC chip to scan
now right now the app is verifying the
identity of this bottle once it's been
verified you can see what why it is this
is the unique ID and if you want to get
more information you have the product
story for the description and in the in
the real world you will also have
logistic information yeah
which technology will be your key to the
blockchain in the future the answer is
not obvious
consider this
now this is a bottle of a 2007 red wine
from the famous wine estate called
Chateau Mouton Rothschild from Bordeaux
France
if it is what it says it is it costs a
whopping 900 US dollars
if it isn't
well take a heart that you're probably
not alone because it is one of the most
counterfeated Wines in China
[Music]
one would expect the distributor of such
rare wines the state-owned direct
imported goods or dig to go with NFC
technology which is more secure and
customizable
but that's not the case
so what are we looking at here so you
could easily find when and also the wine
come from which Winery oh so it also
gives you information off yes the winery
was established in 1882 yeah it's a very
traditional family wine
foreign
Center has more than 200 members they
all interested in tracing systems
they're trying to make all the Chinese
market understand that you can easily
enjoy the wine in a much more safe way
but when we talk about the cost they
think okay it's too much to them three
years ago we used ivid or almost across
one yen for per chips but now if we use
the QR code it's almost maybe 10 cents
if we want more Enterprises to join us
we have to lower the cost of the uh the
tap or the chips so so in the long term
it kind of evens out the cost and also I
think the real gain is the assurance
that you can give your customers right
oh yes to that okay
so now you should bottom up right you
too
[Music]
QR codes cost less which explains why
companies prefer to use this to access
information on their blockchains
such as
I do this
I make a copy of the QR code
and
or this
[Music]
the URL still points to the same link on
the blockchain but the product is
compromised
[Music]
in China blockchain is already playing a
big part in securing the food chain
many food products now come with QR
codes that provide information on where
they come from
but I realize QR codes are far from
foolproof and if I wanted to I could
easily tamper with the content
the URL still points to the same link on
the blockchain but the product is
compromised
to mitigate this Tech entrepreneur Yas
polinski came up with a smart packaging
solution
Yaz is the co-founder of gualimai a
blockchain startup that Imports and
distributes infant formula in China
if you look at the industry right now
there are quite a lot of claims and hype
around blockchain and blockchain and
inevitably solve the problem of fakes
and this is just not the case because
even if happened to scan the fake QR
code it will give you the result of this
record existing on the blockchain and
therefore what's even even worse than a
non-protective product but giving you a
full sense of security that the product
seems to authenticate with the
blockchain therefore it must be true and
this problem essentially is why
blockchain right now it cannot solve the
problem of fakes on its own and
therefore there needs to be something
extra and okay this is what we're doing
so what's this extra thing that needs to
be done to make blockchain really secure
so this extra thing essentially it's a
physical production of the of the
product and the physical production you
need to make sure that there is this
one-to-one correspondence between
blockchain and a physical object
something that you cannot replicate to
an infinite amount of copies so what we
come up with this is uh one of the older
generation of the label but still works
the same so as you can see here we're
protecting the product not just on the
blockchain in terms of like digital
protection but also physical protection
the physical protection and so the claim
that we're making and the promise that
we are given to our consumer is that if
this thing authenticates that means that
the product packaging has not been
tampered with I see so what I see right
now is like a kind of a CU yeah this
looks like some kind of electronic
device under the seal so basically yeah
so this is a this is a label right so it
is based on NFC technology and what you
see in the electronic circuit here is
essentially an antenna which is
connected to an NFC chip as I was doing
as you could see this dial kind of
filling up with the percentages you know
this is when the data exchange happened
with the blockchain and all the
information has been checked with a
blockchain so this is what essential
what the consumer says right so this is
all all the standard things so the
tracking Logistics information some
things about the product and whatever
you want to put in it okay that's like a
huge list of well one of these actually
uh this uh the Scan locations
essentially we use this as a testing
sample so whatever we have taken it in
any of our travels for demonstrations it
would be registered in the blockchain oh
I see as a scanning event okay oh I see
so anyone who scans the blockchain also
the data gets put on an additional block
gets added every time someone scans the
chip to the to the record corresponding
of uh to this particular product ah I
see so why is blockchain the way to go
for you so you see we're not the first
ones who try to solve the problem of
fakes in China consumer already lost any
sense of belief in such claims that uh
okay so you're telling me that you're
only selling genuine things but why
should I believe you if there are you
know 10 other companies that do the same
and they inevitably fail and so
blockchain in this respect it works as a
meta legitimator for us because for us
when we use blockchain our the claim
that we make essentially is that you
don't have to trust us you have to trust
the technology so so as long as you
understand how the technology works we
don't need to be convincing so here it
again it works as a third party
authenticator for us as a business
babies have died after drinking milk
contaminated with melamine 300 000
others became ill obtained to Chinese
milk China's baby milk powder Scandal
fears are growing around the world over
the safety of Chinese milk products
the 2008 milk powder Scandal which
killed six babies and left 300 000
others ill still haunts the Chinese
the crisis of confidence worsened when
yet another fake milk Scandal was
uncovered in Shanghai in late 2015.
12 suspects were implicated for passing
off cheap milk powder from branded
products over 12 000 cans of branded
milk products were compromised
I am a parent
so knowing whether my milk powder has
been tempered with is absolutely
important
of the technology I want to put yaza's
product to the test
I'm meeting his sales manager Duomo at a
store selling the baby products what if
I tried to peel off the sticker very
carefully and to avoid breaking the
circuit yeah you could try you could try
yeah okay I believe you will you will
never die I won't succeed oh it's ruined
yeah of course so this is our physical
protection to prevent any kind of reuse
or recycle for the products but another
thing you need to use yourself on to
track it again so once you you have tear
or ruined the level you couldn't scan
anything oh you see because the
circuit's broken there's no it is the
antenna is broken so once the antenna is
broken the connection to the NFC chip is
totally broken
[Music]
I left China heartened not by the state
of the technology which is a long way to
go before it gets adopted by the
mainstream
but by the smart and talented men and
women I met committed to using
technology to build a better world a
world where we can trust our food
and that's why it matters
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]